if you for domini plus barré
dominique lui balaie les actrices du
frais dominique le barça y chauffe eau
jusqu'à étaient venus tuer le président
et qui est le vice président c'est la
première fois que vous êtes et lieu tous
les 2 eric à ton avis pourquoi tu as été
élu il trouve que sérieux je suis
présentée parce que l'ancienne
présidente avant elle était sérieuse
mais après au bout elle est devenue
moins sérieuses puis à la montée le
mauvais exemple aux élèves
c'est mon sac je me suis présenté est ce
que c'est important de voter oui oui oui
ou quoi mais parce que comme ça il n'y a
pas de jaloux et ce à des partages tout
le monde ça nous instruire un peu et
puis comme ça au moins ma lin président
il n'ya pas qu'ici qu'on vote oui
vous êtes aussi à la mairie qui est-ce
qui élit les députés il faut saisir
deuxième expérience une classe mixte
dans un csg ils ont 14 et 15 ans on
pourrait député faut être au courant de
tous se retrouvent à des débats
télévisés avec avec 2 avec deux députés
on voit qu'ils sont vraiment des
arguments puissants courants tous se
demandent ce qu'ils ont été les chercher
tous ces arguments leur attribue t il
arriver une chose bien ce qui peut
ignorer toute manière pas n'importe qui
peut être dit plus députés 1 sont les
gens bien qu'ils sont pas n'importe qui
peut s'y présenter il faut voir l'argent
il faut avoir une autre construction des
députés qui passe à la télé ou qui
seront en public ils ont des visages
d'anges et puis après quand il sera élu
on voit que ça n'a pas changé beaucoup
plus je pense qu'on s'aperçoit qu'un
député vous quand on a vu ce qu'il a
fait avant d'être de commencer sa
propagande et sa publicité pourrait
députés parce que quand il fait sa
publicité peut nous raconter peut
raconter n'importe quoi et ensuite
changé l'idée je dois pas tellement un
boulot est à bout et intéressant à
savoir tous les papiers à cqpp
responsabilité fun ça je crois que c'est
plutôt pour les pays pour le monroe tête
en finale joué un grand rôle
quand même parce que sinon poids jamais
être représentée par quelqu'un
auprès du gouvernement je vais tout le
monde ne s'intéresse pas à la politique
il y en a qui votent comme ça un peu par
hasard surtout les femmes ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique mais il
ya quand même plus de femmes que
d'hommes alors quand même la vie des
femmes ça qu'on ne faut pas qu'elles
votent comme ça pour rien il faut quand
même savoir dans la politique on voudra
ya beaucoup d'hommes et s'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de femmes mais je trouve ça at
il devrait y avoir menti moitié twitter
quand tu pourra voter est ce que tu veux
train chaque fois oui il celui qui
votent pas il s'est garé un petit peu de
la société c'est à dire il y ait
vraiment pour lui tout seul il pense pas
aux autres
je trouve qu'il ya une chose qui est
regrettable c'est que ici mise en scène
pas fait pour un peu par de la politique
ce qui fait que quand on la voit dans la
vie active qui nous l'a jamais enseigné
mont sera brève puisque c'était le
quartier tout ça on se retrouvera dans
un monde qu'on connaît vos consignes ce
sera justement influencé par ses parades
parce qu'ils passent à la télévision
quoi il ya des gens qui gèrent entrant à
la vie active ils sont parce que c'est
que que ça ils seront là pour voter
[Musique]